en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología y debido a la
situación que vivimos a causa de la
pandemia de kobe 19 nos adaptamos desde
nuestros hogares para llevarles toda la
información -soy valentina torres
sánchez gracias por acompañarme
iniciamos este espacio hablando de la
candidata vacuna desarrollada por la
farmacéutica estadounidense y fisher y
la alemana biotech porque ambas
compañías indicaron que el fármaco según
los datos preliminares de su fase 3
tiene una efectividad de más del 90 por
ciento contra el cob y 19 esta es la
primera cifra de eficacia que se conoce
de una candidata vacuna albert burla
director ejecutivo de facer indicó que
aunque son resultados intermedios y no
finales demuestran que el medicamento si
previene que los adultos que no han sido
diagnosticados contraigan este virus
y machine es exactamente como lo
imaginamos es un gran día para la
ciencia es un gran día para la humanidad
es increíble darse cuenta de que la
vacuna tiene una efectividad del 90 por
ciento
[Música]
entiendes que las esperanzas de millones
de personas de empresas de cientos de
gobiernos estaban sobre tus hombros
ahora pienso podemos decirlo con certeza
creo que podemos ver la luz al final del
túnel
43 mil 500 personas han participado en
este ensayo clínico en 6 países y hasta
el momento no se han encontrado
problemas serios de seguridad los
responsables prevén solicitar la
autorización de uso de emergencia en
eeuu a finales de este mes para poder
aplicarla a personas entre los 16 y los
85 años el dato fue celebrado por la
organización mundial de la salud a
través de su cuenta de twitter el
secretario general de la oms se destacó
que el mundo está experimentando
innovación y experimentación siempre
para acabar con la pandemia justamente
para una parte de la comunidad
científica lo más importante para
resaltar es la forma en la que se están
desarrollando las vacunas que están en
pruebas actualmente
este es un modo completamente nuevo de
generar una vacuna los expertos han
estado tratando este método por muchos
años sin éxito y es tomar una pequeña
pieza de material genético llamado a rn
mensajero muchas copias de él que se le
inyectan a la gente en el músculo y esas
células musculares toman la pieza de rn
mensajero y fabrican proteínas del virus
e mail
no es el virus como tal pero pequeñas
piezas del virus y el sistema inmune la
reconoce como extrañas y genera una
respuesta inmune
los datos publicados se exponen que se
necesitan dos dosis de la inyección con
tres semanas de intervalo los ensayos se
han efectuado en eeuu alemania brasil
argentina sudáfrica y turquía y muestran
que la protección del 90% se logra 7
después de la segunda dosis el anuncio
ha sido celebrado ampliamente no
obstante algunos científicos han
mostrado y pedido cautela al recordar
que estos son resultados preliminares
pues aún no ha finalizado la fase 3 de
pruebas asimismo han destacado que se
necesita un tiempo prudencial para
determinar el periodo de protección que
ofrece el fármaco es decir cuánto tiempo
sería efectiva la vacuna desde el
momento en que empieza a actuar para
proteger al cuerpo del cobi 19
we know that is back si nos gustaría
saber más sobre los datos de seguridad
sabemos que esta es una vacuna que
podemos llamar reactogénicas causa
varias reacciones locales dolor en los
brazos dolor durante la inyección
algunas personas se pueden sentir
débiles durante un día o dos y pueden
presentar dolor de cabeza y la segunda
dosis porque es una vacuna de dos dosis
generalmente duele más que la primera
así que tendremos que permitir que la
gente sepa eso y conocer más detalles
y claro se ha realizado un seguimiento
por un periodo corto de tiempo para ver
que no haya efectos adversos serios
potencialmente relacionados con la
vacuna esto tendrá que continuar luego
de que empecemos a usar el fármaco en la
población general
y vamos ahora está rusia porque luego de
que se conociera este anuncio de facer y
biotech representantes del gobierno de
moscú indicaron que su vacuna conocida
como sputnik 5 también tiene una
efectividad que supera el 90% según los
responsables del fármaco sputnik 5 tiene
un valor agregado y es que no hace parte
de una prueba científica sino que se
está aplicando al público en general
este medicamento fue registrado en el
país en agosto pasado y desde entonces
generó una gran polémica entre la
comunidad científica que indicaba que no
había completado las pruebas requeridas
se estima que en total la vacuna fue
estudiada durante unos 2
y desde que se registró hace tres meses
ha sido aplicada a la población en rusia
sin que se hayan publicado resultados
oficiales de su efectividad y seguridad
en principio rusia construyó una alianza
para producir este fármaco en 5 países y
se comprometió a fabricar 500 millones
de dosis en 12 meses para finalizar
cambiamos radicalmente de tema y
hablamos de hyper loop este sistema de
transporte que desarrolla la firma
virgin y que terminó con éxito su
primera prueba con pasajeros hyper lupa
es un sistema que consiste en una serie
de tubos gigantes por los que viajan
unas cápsulas que le evitan y se
desplazan a más de mil kilómetros por
hora
hegel ilusión fueron los dos
trabajadores del proyecto elegidos para
participar en esta prueba en la que
recorrieron 500 metros en sólo 15
segundos así concluimos este espacio
cuídense si es posible quédense en casa
recuerden que la salud es lo más
importante a ustedes gracias por su
compañía y recuerden que pueden
continuar con más en france 24 y
france24 puntocom
[Música]